y en directo a le doy la bienvenida en
el estudio a marina sardenya periodista
de la redacción de france 24 porque en
colombia culminaron este jueves los 3
días de audiencias públicas el
reconocimiento ante la jurisdicción
especial para la paz un cara a cara
entre el último secretariado de la
guerrilla fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias de colombia farc y las
víctimas del secuestro marina bienvenida
cuéntenos en qué ha consistido el
encuentro y por qué es tan importante
para la paz en colombia' androides por
primera vez y durante tres días desde el
pasado martes siete miembros comandantes
de las guerrillas de las farc se
sentaron a reconocer ya escuchar a las
víctimas de secuestros perpetrados por
la organización durante el conflicto
armado colombiano que duró durante más
de cinco décadas recordemos que esto es
un hecho inédito y que no podría haber
tenido lugar sin los acuerdos de paz que
firmaron la guerrilla de las farc con el
estado colombiano
entonces 1016 este reconocimiento se
hacen mal en el marco del caso 01 toma
de rehenes graves privaciones de la
libertad y otros crímenes concurrentes
cometidos por las farc ep que investiga
a la gente
que fue una política interna de la
organización de la exguerrillera entre
los años 1993 y 2012 dejando al menos 21
mil
396 víctimas oficiales las farc
admitieron realizar secuestros en todo
el país en tres modalidades para hacer
intercambios de guerrilleros presos para
financiar su accionar armado y para
hacer control territorial un crimen de
lesa humanidad que llevó a la
degradación de la guerrilla como los
mismos comandantes aceptaron la primera
es el primer en el primer día de
audiencia el máximo dirigente de la
organización rodrigo londoño alias
timochenko asumió su responsabilidad
individual y colectiva entre las
víctimas y sus familiares se encontraban
civiles empresarios miembros de la
fuerza pública y políticos que relataron
duros testimonios de las violaciones
vejaciones torturas violencia sexual
desaparición forzada
esclavitud o extorsiones que las farc le
realizaron durante los cautiverios
algunos prolongados hasta 13 años si
bien la mayoría de las víctimas
presentes se hablaban de pasar página y
de reconciliación la herida es profunda
como dijo el ex congresista orlando
beltrán secuestrado durante ocho años
que llamó a los líderes de las farc
presentes asesinos y genocidas el
miércoles el policía césar lazos se puso
en pie al 3 ante el tribunal y sus
victimarios con una cadena en el cuello
la misma en la misma que tuvo que llevar
durante ocho años de secuestro durante
los secuestros muchas víctimas fueron
sometidas a humillantes trabajos
forzados un delito conexo catalogado de
esclavitud y que inicialmente las farc
fueron reacios a reconocer también
participaron los familiares de víctimas
de desaparición durante sus cautiverio
si es que al menos 148 personas
secuestradas nunca volvieron a sus casas
con sus familias tras su desmovilización
las farc conformaron la comisión de
búsqueda de desaparecidos en las que
trabajan mano a mano víctimas y
victimarios en un intento por encontrar
los restos de los desaparecidos por la
guerrilla
marine cuéntenos que viene ahora para
las víctimas y para los víctimas es
andrés si bien no es la primera vez que
algunos se sientan cara a cara con los
autores de estos crímenes por primera
vez la cúpula de las farc reconocen la
atrocidad de sus crímenes su orden y los
asesinatos en un acto simbólico pero
también político para las para que los
desmovilizados puedan acceder no sólo a
las sanciones de la justicia
transicional sino al perdón colectivo
del pueblo colombiano que todavía mira
con incredulidad el indulto por las
acciones cometidas por las farc tras las
audiencias del siguiente paso es la
imputación de cargos y que la jefe emita
una condena que depende del grado de
verdad y aceptación de culpa que hagan
los imputados y que podrían implicar la
privación de libertad porque está
principalmente enfocada a la reparación
de las miles de víctimas de este brutal
crimen
marian abajo de la redacción de france
24 muchas gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en directo américa seguimos con más